bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous par
téléphone ce soir comment est ce que
vous avez accueilli l'annoncé de ce
couvre feu généralisé à 18 heures dès
demain bonsoir bien depuis plusieurs
jours le bruit court il court est
tellement fort qu'il avait déjà calé
dire le on est désespérés parce que
c'est l'heure la plus importante pour
les commerçants cette dernière heure 70
% du commerce se fait de l'après-midi et
70% cession semble pourtant se fait
entre 16h30 et 19h donc ça va être
compliqué on va faire en gros 20 % du
chiffre d'affaires donc ça devient
dramatique mais ce n'est rien à côté
bien d'un confinement total où on en
rêve plus du tout exercer voilà c'est la
part fille plein hiver alors comment les
abris comment est-ce que les cornes les
commerçants s'organisent
comment est-ce qu'ils s'organisent
rapidement aussi puisque c'est à partir
de demain que cette couvre feu
généralisé entre en vigueur à partir de
18 heures s'ouvrant beaucoup de
commerçants les centre-villes ouvre à 11
donc là ils vont ouvrir à viseur est
fermé à 18h ils ont la même amplitude
horaire donc pour les salariés ça décale
juste leurs débuts de travail et la fin
du travail mais ça ne se change pas
fondamentalement le nombre d'heures
travaillées
top cops est pas là dessus qu'on va
jouer ce qui va jouer c'est que dans
salariés aussi faut qu'ils arrêtent de
travailler on ferme à 18 heures donc ça
va être compliqué pour eux pour faire
les courses pour l'essentiel dont ils
ont besoin pour le nombre serait
compliqué à nous aussi imaginer
peut-être des solutions d'horaires
variable pour que certains arrivent plus
tard le matin pour laisser du temps pour
aller faire ses approvisionnements de
bata moi je voudrais dire à l'ensemble
des pensé qu' il faut commercer le matin
il faut aller chez les commerçants le
matin que c'est là où il ya le moins de
monde donc c'est là où l'on rencontre
aura le moins de personnes avec le
moindre risque et ça permettra
aux commerçants de survivre en arrêtant
de compter sur les aides publiques les
cas bien souvent les aides publiques
sont des prêts et les prêts il faudra
les rembourser
c'est à peu près comme si on disait à
chômeurs on a tu t'inscris au chômage je
te prête de l'argent coulant bras quand
tu travailles rail comme tu vas pouvoir
financer ton chômage vous inviter les
français à venir faire leurs courses tôt
le matin mais c'est tout le monde si
votre exemple évidemment ça va être la
concentration dans les magasins à une
même heure comment est ce qu'on fait
pour
comment est ce que les commerçants
s'organisent pour faire en sorte que le
flux soient étalés sur toute la journée
jusqu'à 18 heures nous on peut pas gérer
l'envi de des clients donc c'est les
clients qui vont voir comment ils
s'organisent
j'espère que les gens qui sont
télétravail qui démarre à 9 heures qui
font une petite pause qui termine à 18
heures gars il va y avoir des
aménagements d'horaires pour qu'il
puisse sortir quand ils puissent
consommer c'est ça fait là minimum des
choses il faut que aussi bien les
salariés mais comme les patrons
s'organise pour que la france continue à
fonctionner tout le monde a intérêt à ce
que la chaîne économique ne se rompent
pas donc tout le monde a intérêt à
s'organiser pour que les commerçants
puissent fonctionner normalement ça va
avoir un impact aussi sur les seuls qui
commence la semaine prochaine avec
beaucoup de stock à liquider cette année
ben bien entendu que ça va avoir de
l'impact qu'on espère juste c'est que à
la fin des hauts lieux des soldes on
soit pas confiner les mots du premier
ministre concernant leur confident
immédiat si jamais les les chiffres
étaient pas bon nous laisse à penser que
compte tenu de l'arrivée le sangler dans
quinze jours on est confiné
c'était un peu dramatique néron le sens
arriver donc vous allez dire aux clients
bardot n'est fait comme vous pouvez mais
venez acheter
de toutes les façons dans l'est dans la
métropole bordelaise on peut travailler
le dimanche maintenant donc à bordeaux
sa fille jouer quelqu'un des choix de
l'ensemble de la métropole
on peut ouvrir le dimanche donc y'a pas
de soucis
ça permet d'étaler sur une journée de
plus pour pouvoir consommer hier la
ministre de l'économie a annoncé que
l'état allait prendre en charge 70 % des
coûts fixes non couverts des entreprises
fermées administrativement ou des
secteurs liés à ses activités ce que la
majorité des commerçants sont concernés
non tant qu'on est ouvert on n'a pas le
droit à ces aides l'a fait pour tous les
secteurs d'activités qui sont fermées je
veux dire c'est tout l'événementiel les
bars les restaurants et tout ce qui est
lié à ce secteur d'activité
les commerçants qui sont ouverts ils
sont pas fermées ni rapidement
donc on a pas moi tout ça vous avez
généreusement urssaf nous a donné ça
fait cadeau de 1000 euros le mois
dernier voilà on a droit à 1500 euros
tous les mois
mais comme on est dans une métropole
bien souvent le loyer rien que le loyer
personnel et des commerçants et de ce
niveau là bon il faut savoir que
beaucoup de commerçants depuis six mois
ne touche pas un centime de leur
entreprise c'est maintenant les patrons
qui font vivre leur entreprise ou
luxations les entreprises qui les femmes
libres c'est ça la notion économique du
commerce
les joueurs comme elle je prends des
risques je gagne de l'argent pour vivre
et ce n'est pas l'un vers oran ce moment
c'est ça on est à l'invers faits sont
bien souvent on renfloue les entreprises
pour pouvoir les faire durer dans le
temps
merci beaucoup d'avoir un prix le temps
de réagir sur notre antenne christian
paul président de l'association
commerçants et artisans des métropoles
de france